9 heures du matin les pelles et les
pioches en main direction les îlots pour
ce petit groupe de dix bénévoles et
amateurs d'ornithologie les sternes sont
toutes parties mais il n'y a pas de
temps à perdre
ce qu'on veut c'est des végétalisée au
maximum le point haut de lille pour que
les sternes et plus de place pour
reproduire ce que parce que les sternes
cherche surtout bas c'est d'avoir deux
maximum d'espèces dégagé sanaa noumane
d'oiseaux qui commence très sauvage donc
bas cette année on a une veste r non on
n'y chez sur cet îlot et on espère l'an
prochain match n'aura pu s'endormir en
leur laissant plus de place
et s'ils ont des visiteurs exploitent
tous les ans basescu s'est plus passé en
hauteur et il y aura plus de l'îlot pour
pour les sternes
durant tout le mois de septembre neuf
chantiers sont prévus entre amboise et
savonnières c'est le dernier endroit en
france
à l'intérieur des terres où l'on peut
croiser cette visiteuse d'été externe
arrivent d'afrique de l'ouest arrive en
france au mois de fin mars avril pour
commencer à nicher et donc elle commence
à s'installer sur les vidéos en mai juin
et donc voilà
aniche en fait à creusot sol leur venir
directement dans le sable pour ça que je
pense à qu'on fait ça ces hirondelles
des maires comme on les appelle sont
très sensibles au changement de leur
habitat la modification des rivières et
la pollution des eaux ont détruit de
nombreux sites de nidification
mais la première menace reste l'homme
les sternes en fait quand elles sont
dérangés s envole et du coup leur reste
la faim reste au soleil l'année
particulièrement parce qu'il a fait très
chaud donc les hummer en fait des
embryons leurs consignes on sait les
poussins enfin quand les poussins sont
dérangés ils peuvent se jeter à l'eau et
ils savent pas encore nager on combat et
c'est loin toutefois plus de 200
poussins ont pris leur envol à la fin du
mois d'août
il faudra attendre quelques mois avant
de voir réapparaître dans le ciel la
fine silhouette au ventre blanc et au
dos argenté